Speaker 1: Another incredible moment during
yesterday's committee hearings.
The January six Trump riot committee hearing
was when a rioter showed up, said he regrets
everything and explains that he was duped
by Trump.
We're going to be looking at video here of
January six rioter Stephen Ayers, who testified
to the January six committee under oath.
And one of the fascinating parts of this is
we've had this vague question, were the rioters
really paying attention to what Trump said?
So the defense that's often made as, listen,
a lot of these people, they came from far
away to Washington, D.C.
It couldn't possibly have been what Trump
said at noon that made them go and riot at
1 p.m..
And of course, this is a very shortsighted
analysis.
It's barely an analysis because the the sort
of incitement to that event started well before
January six.
But we're actually going to hear from Rioter
himself, Stephen Ayers tells us during his
testimony, Yeah, you know, if Trump earlier
had said, go home, we would have gone home.
We thought that's what he wanted us to do.
So let's go to the first clip.
How did he end up there and does he still
believe the election was stolen?
Because, remember, the reason for the rioting
was the election was stolen by Joe Biden and
we've got to take it back.
Stephen Ayers was asked about this interesting
answer.
Speaker 2: You know, that's basically what
got me to come down here.
And do you still believe the election was
stolen?
Not so much now.
I got away from all the social media.
When January six happened, I basically deleted
it all.
You know, I started doing my own research
and everything and.
For me, for me.
Speaker 1: For me.
I mean, his own research got him into this
problem in the first place, but it's still
interesting to listen to.
Speaker 2: It got to be that.
To actually for that to actually take place
would be it's too big.
You know, there'd be there's no way to keep
something like that quiet as big as something
like that.
You know, with all the you know, all the lawsuits
being shot down one after another, that that
was mainly what convinced me.
Speaker 1: So this is someone who either has
been coached or is willing to see a reason.
I mean, everything he's saying is completely
true.
The problem is we knew all of this on January
5th of 2021.
60 lawsuits went nowhere.
That information was available on January
5th before anyone decided to show up, before
anyone actually showed up and right it, maybe
they had decided already.
The fact that such a conspiracy would require
so many moving parts and so many people to
be involved.
It was election officials and precinct monitors
and state officials and federal people coordinating
and the people controlling the machine.
Speaker 3: We're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that analysis was available
to Stephen Ayers on January 5th.
So listen, this guy is in trouble.
He potentially has been coached, but it's
still interesting to hear what he had to say.
Now.
Later, Ayers testified that when Trump said
on Twitter, It's time for you to go.
They decided to go.
They were, as far as they believed, doing
whatever Trump wanted them to do.
Speaker 3: Tweet I believe that included a
video telling people to go home.
Did you see that and did that have any effect
on what you were doing.
Speaker 2: When we were there?
As soon as that come out, everybody started
talking about it and it seemed like it started
to disperse.
You know, some of the crowd, obviously, you
know, once we got back to the hotel room,
we seen that it was still going on, but it
definitely dispersed a lot of the crowd.
Speaker 3: And did you leave at that point?
Speaker 2: We did.
Yeah, we left.
Speaker 3: So in other words, that was the
key moment when you decided to leave, when
President Trump told people to go home?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, we left.
Right when that come out.
Speaker 1: So very clear.
They were there because of Trump.
And when Trump said go home, they left it
very hard to argue that Trump had nothing
to do with this.
He actually said Stephen Ayers did later in
his testimony.
If Trump had tweeted to leave earlier, they
wouldn't even have been there in the first
place.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think everybody thought
he was going to be coming down.
You know, he said in his speech, you know,
it's kind of like he's going to be there with
us.
Wow.
I mean, I think I believe that.
Speaker 4: We know that you illegally entered
the Capitol that afternoon and then left the
Capitol area later on.
What made you decide to leave?
Speaker 2: Basically, when President Trump
put his tweet out.
We literally left right after that come out.
You know.
To me if he would have done that earlier in
the day, 130, you know that we wouldn't be
in this.
Maybe we wouldn't be in this bad of a situation
or something.
Speaker 1: Whatever you think about Stephen
Ayers, whatever his intentions are now.
And listen, I'm right there with you.
This guy has every he's going to tell us in
a moment in the next clip.
His life is ruined.
He lost his job.
He had to sell his house.
He has an interest in portraying himself as
the reformed, clear thinking former Trump
guy who denounces everything.
No question about it.
It's abundantly clear that they were paying
attention to what they believed Donald Trump
wanted.
Trump made it seem like he was going to march
with them down to the Capitol.
Stephen Ayers testified to that as well.
All right.
Last clip here.
Ayers says this has ruined his life and that
makes sense.
Do we feel bad?
Well, you tell me.
I mean, if you believe in personal responsibility,
he made these decisions.
Speaker 3: Looking back on it now, how do
you reflect on the role that you played in
the crowd that day and what is going on in
your life?
Speaker 2: Basically, you know, I lost my
job since this all happened, you know?
Pretty much sold my house.
So everything that happened with the charges.
You know, thank God a lot of them did get
dismissed because I was just holding my phone,
but at the same time, I was there.
So, I mean, it definitely it changed my life,
you know, and not for the good.
Definitely not for the, you know, for the
better.
Yeah.
I mean.
Speaker 1: Well, so whatever your thought
is on how honest Stephen Ayers was in the
testimony or whatever else the important things
here are, number one, these people were genuinely
duped by Trump and the people around him.
Now we can say we don't care.
We can say they deserved it.
We can say that it was their responsibility.
These are adults.
I'm with you.
But they were duped by Trump.
And so the idea that Trump was an irrelevant
player here, absolutely untrue.
Secondly, the idea that had Trump called them
off earlier, they would have left at least
Stephen Ayers is saying, of course, we were
we were following what we understood to be
Donald Trump's direction.
And that is another key component here.
So a fascinating day.
And it is expected that next week there's
going to be another blockbuster day of testimony,
which we will, of course, be covering for
you on the podcast and potentially live as
well.
Let me know your thoughts about Stephen Ayers
as a witness.
Smart to bring him.
Not smart.
Did we learn anything or not?
I think it was an absolutely great decision.
Some people emailed me, said I didn't get
the point of this testimony.
Oh, I got the point.
The point was was very clear, and I think
it was a good decision.
Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
podcast, YouTube channel, radio show and TV
show.
You can sign up at Join Packman dot com.
You'll get the daily bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams of
the show and so many other great things.
You can sign up and join Packman Scum and
the coupon code available if you'd like.
It is big voting.
22 saves you, saves you a lot.
I think it's more than 50 or 60%.
It's a good deal.
Join Pack MEDCOM is
the place to do it.